well the las vegas wedding industry  coming together for celebration tonight  the local wedding chamber of commerce  hosting its fifth birthday at the strat  the group is made up of leaders in the  industry who help make our city the  wedding capital of the world they're  also looking forward to a big 2021 even  though 2020  only saw a little bit more than a 20  percent drop in weddings  as other industries really collapsed  weddings were resilient  and they really saved a lot of small  businesses  and individual incomes so it's an  important legacy industry that we just  need to make sure  it continues and grows this year  is already off to a pretty strong start  thanks in part to 4-3-2-1  earlier this month as many as the  thousand couples said i do that day  which is three to five times a typical  saturday in las vegas